les 18 35 ans font désormais plus de
chirurgie esthétique que les plus de 50
ans les médecins ont même donné un nom à
ce phénomène
on appelle le snack ya l'histoire du
snap shot syndrome stade chat syndrome
voilà qui est qu'on a décrit nous les
médecins qui nous occupons des jeunes ça
veut dire qu'en fait ils prennent une
photo dans snapshot
ils font des filtres et ils viennent
nous voir en nous demandant de
ressembler à leurs filtres lors ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que c'est nous
donnons pas de ressembler un acteur qui
est pas
vous pouvez encore leur répondre c'est
pas vous c'est difficile la hyène avec
la photo de même transformé et ses
demandes d'embellissement et pas de
rajeunissement c'est ça qui est nouveau
voilà alors c'est vrai que l'on va
revoir d'autres extraits gain de ce set
à vide qui est contre pied pour
d'ailleurs gilbert des dépôts oui on
parle pas qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est
inéluctable effectivement on vous
ressemblez que sa photo et fit alors on
peut le regretter mais si les jeunes ne
changent pas leur visage s'ils en ont
envie
ils vont être malheureux toute leur vie
mais thébaux solution mais il aurait
donné il faut être accompagné
c'est un processus de changement beau
jeu vous dire ce sont sans filtre vous
êtes isabelle windows fait si j'avais pu
je te rends compte de ce que tu dis oui
oui vous êtes malheureux toute leur vie
une espèce de vérité que tu as scène
comme ça au comptant ce qui prime c'est
une liste où là dessus et risque d'être
malheureux tenus marie bien sûr mais non
mais je trouve ça mais dote d'une
dangerosité ce que tu dis mais à béret
ce que je dis est vrai c'est ça qui
dérange
s'il vous plaît on a un guillaume genton
vous avez bien fait de la chirurgie
sinon jamais moi je pense clairement que
instagram et la télé réalité ont créé
des complexes et des jeunes je vous
donnais un chiffre 24 % des jeunes se
sentent complexées par leur corps après
avoir regardé des émissions de
téléréalité donc ça veut dire quoi
servent aujourd'hui c'est sûr nous
regardant que vous êtes complexée
kim kardashian les filles tous les mecs
venaient de body buildé c'est dommage
parce qu'on a des filles qui se
ressemblent toutes d'ailleurs l'un des
candidats de télé rites et qu'on
n'arrive plus à distinguer aujourd'hui
alors que céder nos imperfections qui
font la beauté de chaque invention
trouve ça vraiment dommage ce que vous
dites perfection il faut venir passer la
perfection benjamin ouais je préfère
parfait non mais ça ils vont vous êtes
très beau la version vous n'êtes pas
parfaits innocents guy hands off you
came from géré la chose esthétique c'est
fait pour réparer
non à la russie et des adolescents des
ou alors des jeunes adultes qui ont des
problèmes corps physique qui sont
malheureux et des oreilles qui t'ont
décoller s'il a envie d'aller mieux dans
leur tête
grâce à ces nouvelles salades après la
effectivement les excès non mais
franchement il n'y a pas de raison de
dire oh vous êtes je ne vais pas axer la
géorgie non m'attaque pas ça mais c'est
pas là si la température au gie si
benjamin ouï fm vieillit pas gagné moi
c'est le bois c'est le frère de sydney
qui me fait baver les pollutions
ah oui et ciné opéra ma maman il ya 25
ans qui a fait vos lèvres alors personne
je n'ai pas d'éléments en fait je parle
j'ai peur je n'ai pas le déroff à sydney
pour cette personne qu'elle soit
parfaite merci c'est un coup de poing à
tavel a reçu un coup de poing merci à
sydney vous êtes sûrs aux esthétiques
très connu un symbole très sérieux sinon
je te le dire les gens d'un ciné c'est
les gens décider pour eux c'est une
légende aussi parce que je sais que siné
refuse ai dit certaines opérations dit
non mais dis donc voilà non non il dit
oui dit non mais il peut dire non et il
laisse pas faire n'importe quoi alors je
peux dire non mais il m'est arrivé dire
oui et là j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à
vous écouter parce que vous avez
refléter ce que j'ai vécu cet après midi
dans ma consultation ce que j'ai vécu
hier dans la consultation avec des jeux
que c'est tous les jours ça fait trente
ans que je consulte que j'opère et j'ai
vu l'évolution il ya 30 ans bredy que
des jeunes de 15 ans viendrait en
consultation j'aurais jamais imaginé
remarquez on n'aurait pas imaginé que
les réseaux existerait donc ce qui se
passe comme l'a très bien dit il y a de
plus en plus de complexer jeunes a causé
réseau a posé filtre ça a été dit
alors comment ça se manifeste dans nos
cabinets et bien il arrive de plus en
plus souvent en consultation d'où ce
pourcentage plus élevé notre travail à
nous c'est pas de dire oui ou non c'est
pas pour ou contre
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de cas à
nuancer une jeune fille de 15 ans qui
fait 1 120 ou un sont eux de poitrine
vous pouvez pas lui dire ça 15 ans
voir tu reviendras une jeune fille de 16
17 ans qui a vraiment une bosse et
disgracieuses ça veut dire que gilles
vous auriez pu tout faire la preuve
appartenait c'est que ça choquerait
aucun de vous ici d'avoir un enfant de 8
ans 9 ans est tout à fait complexée à
l'école par des oreilles d'azur faire
face aux colonnes et qui se refait pas
les oreilles et bien c'est la même chose
ça mais là c'est sure you - l'élève -
qui me dérangeait lapin qui arrive une
fille complètement plate pardon presque
ils n'ont rien volé une fille
complètement plate et bien c'est gênant
même si elle est un peu de poitrine faut
pas louper rayonnant docteur avant une
grossesse qui sont restés très joli avec
une pré peu de poids telle étude jette
partout c'est qu'avant ça se sait
étudier dans le monde entier donc sensé
mais qu'est ce qui a fait ce
développement et bien c'est ce que vous
venez de dire syrie le développement de
techniques soft c'est à dire que
maintenant qu'il y a d'acide
hyaluronique sassano botox ça n'existait
pas il ya presque 15 en un an qu'il ya
les petits peeling qu'il ya tout un tas
de techniques de rajeunissement le
mésolift est bien celle qui viennent
pour cela en accepte de le faire
lorsqu'elles prennent des petits actes
s'il faut commencer dès 20 ans par le
botox c'est une erreur bien sûr j'en ai
fait mais moi j'ai commencé à faire à 35
ans ah ouais donc moi j'assume watts et
moi je viens tout en l'air on en rigole
ici le fait que ben bella à l heure où
la voix hier on la rend leur connaît pas
on est on connaît mais moi c'est un vrai
complexe et j'ai fait déjà après mais
mes trois accouchements qui a accouché
trois fois à 35 ans quand effectivement
je commence à voir le visage un peu
marqué fatigue etc
j'avais envie c'est pas parce que vous
baigner aussi dans la téléralité tout le
temps parce que moi j'estime que déjà je
suis assez grande pour savoir ce que je
fais et je n'ai pas besoin de me calquer
à quelqu'un et je déconseille aux gens
de ce qu'est de vivre en se calquant sur
les autres ça c'est n'importe quoi et
les jeunes pour moi déjà ça doit être
interdite en dessous de 18 ans déjà
c'est une interdiction pour moi mais
c'est ferme il ya aucune de mes filles
qui fera date chirurgie ou quoi que ce
soit ni les injections avant 18 ans et
encore parce que comme il le dit la
docteure c'est vraiment même en tout fin
à partir de 20 25 ans les injections 25
ans je pense c'est 27 à peu près voire
mieux la trentaine par contre le botox
oui c'est préventif ça évite les rides
du lion de ce faut faire la différence
entre des injections alors matt mason
vous avez quel âge 24 ans vous avez fait
quoi vous j'ai fait la poitrine le nez
deux fois l'élève le coin des yeux
pottoks au front et des facettes
un beau palmarès et vous sentez mieux
maintenant je me sens très bien
c'est vrai vous étiez mais c'était pour
faire comme les autres où ces prêts
parce que vous étiez où vous sentiez
vous sentiez pas belle merci c'est
l'entente on vous voit ses mondiale at
il assuré non je ressemblais à merci
mais j'ai fait ça juste parce que ça me
permet de me sentir mieux dans mon corps
et je les fais de manière réfléchie
bien que j'étais jeune quand j'ai
commencé mieux quel âge et 24 ans
j'avais j'avais 19 ans la première
opération a même jeté mon complexe mais
après dragon vous interroger sur ce qui
serait arrivé sur une rame est prévue
ben je n'ai pas l'intention de m'arrêter
tout de suite tant que j'aurai déjà
volume sur scène c'est pourquoi j'ai
envie de refaire mes mollets très
complexée mes jambes du goudron refus
des mollets parce qu'on fait des mollets
mais lors je pensais que l'air du temps
c'était pouvoir disposer de son corps
comme on l'entend et j'estime que c'est
pas dangereux pour la santé par mois que
de fumer ou ou se droguer de faire des
vacances là dedans alors parce que ça
coûte cher
non pas tout mon argent mais une bonne
partie se passe de mon argent de la
manière dont je le veux donc gestion que
et vont bien ils vouent leur avait
demandé leur avis avant de faire toutes
ces opérations pas du tout je demande
toujours la vie de mes parents
mais voyez vous un moment c'est comme si
vous allez acheter des petits écoliers
chez vous en fait tout le temps non j'en
fais pas tout le temps mais il est dur
c'est mon corps et qu' ils ont pas d'une
part au queen's ou moins vraies plus ou
moins par an vous n'avez pas peur que ça
devienne une sorte d'addiction c'est à
dire que puisque de toute façon par
essence personne n'est parfait et tant
mieux que vous cherchez cette perfection
ses deux roues sans jamais pardon de
vous ça passe et que donc vous chercher
cette perfection et que vous ne la
petite teigne et jamais donc mais donc
continuer cette quête incessante et
chaque année retournées sur la table
d'opération est temps que ça me procure
une satisfaction et que ça me fait me
sentir mieux dans ma peau je vois pas le
après si je peux me permettre sur miles
and franchement ça ne se voit pas du
tout oui mais on sait que c'est très
bien c'est parce que j'ai un super
chirurgien qui n'est pas me dire non
quand je veux vraiment vous c'est réussi
on va pas se mentir et maïs allait bien
mais prévient c'est à dire que vous le
dites sur vos réseaux que la plupart de
vos photos sont retouchées avec
photoshop parce que les jeunes y a le
syndrome snapshot tous veulent
ressembler un fils mais aussi aux
influenceurs et la mode de cette bouche
que vous détestez syrie a été lancé par
kylie il ya une recrudescence après dans
le monde entier et on veut ressembler
aux influenceurs mais c'est une chimère
on peut pas ressembler à quelque chose
qui n'existe pas et au moins maïssane
prévient de ça que toutes les photos
sont photoshopée alors un message juste
dans six ans j'ai une question à poser à
signer ce que vous avez déjà fait de la
chirurgie esthétique vous oui à oui tu
complètement chauve et depuis quelle
technique coréenne à oyonnax jette les
cheveux en lui-même en injectant une
petite seringue
je me retrouve avec des cheveux et je
trouve ça tout à fait normal pas moi je
fais du botteur faire sinon c'est comme
un enfant
je n'aime pas avoir les rites remarqué à
vous l'avez fait ça soit parce que dans
franchement vous avez un épiderme
magnifique est important c'est votre
outil de travail comme si rocco siffredi
avec cuisine les jeunes de 25 ans qui
viennent me voir ainsi donc tu fais pas
moi je ne suis pas choqué par le
discours que quelques unes maitane par
contre dire qu'il n'ya aucun risque
c'est excessif il n'y a pas de risque
zéro il ya chaque fois j'ai chaque fois
vu des complications sur sans prothèse
mammaire on peut y avoir une infection
donc il faut pas dire c'est les géants
peut le faire aimer c'est moins
dangereux que de fumer des cigarettes
par exemple fréquent donc moins
dangereux que de fumer deux paquets
d'accord que par jour d'accord je suis
pas très naturelle des loyers mois titre
personnage
moi j'ai des ados et j'aimerais pas
qu'elle calzaghe et chez un chirurgien
esthétique sauf bien sûr vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure pour une chirurgie
réparatrice en et deux oreilles
décollées un gros complexe quelque chose
vraiment qu'ils les bronzes tellement
qu'on peut même pas sortir de chez soi
et ça ça arrive plus moi je pense un
petit peu comme valérie je pense que
c'est quand même un sorte de cercle
vicieux
en fait et en fait on s'en sort jamais
parce qu'il ya toujours quelque chose
qui va vous exactement
enfin vous allez être insatisfait de
quelque chose tout le temps en terre
battue commence ses travaux à la maison
exactement parce qu'il est
toujours une nouvelle brique toujours un
nouveau carnage et moi qui travaillais
dans la mode par exemple je peux vous
dire que par exemple il ya 30 ans quand
j'étais mannequin en fait la mode
n'était pas du tout comme aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs qu'on détestait les gros
seins et ont détesté les fesses
rebondies et donc au final vous vous
auriez pas d'appel a finalement est ce
qu'on voulait faire un corps qui est à
la mode d'aujourd'hui qui ne le sera
plus ou qui ne vous plaira plus de huit
ans il sera trop tard pour revenir en
arrière
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux pas je ne sais
pas moi je ne juge pas et jamais d'avis
mais est-ce que c'est pas mieux de
s'assumer telle qu'on ait un minimum
est-ce que vous façonné à quelque chose
qui va plaire aujourd'hui pour passer
dans les enjeux les marseillais avaient
quand même par une esthétique très
pornographiques et est ce que dans dix
ans dans 15 ans dans 20 ans est ce que
ce sera toujours au goût du jour
voilà mais moi je viens d'arriver la
phrase à des mara 18 géraldine je pense
que la téléralité jour du faut arrêter
de dire c'est à cause de latérite et
comme tu l'as dit guillaume
c'est pas vrai parce que dans télé
réalité il ya des filles refaite et des
filles pas du tour fait vous avez des
filles super naturel en fait juste le
roi la majorité de la société
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que latéralité
il ya toutes sortes de filles d'accord
parce que on est les familles seulement
et c'est que c'est le refus de la
société c'est pas la télé réalité il ya
paillage et radio télé réalité vous avez
des candidates qui ne sont absolument
pas beaucoup réseaux sociaux vous avez
vous fait quoi vous moi j'ai refait les
singes effet délits possibles de tombes
à doter mais j'ai fait les cernes
j'ai fait des vrais chirurgie les chiens
ne met pas du tout c'est non mais parce
que j'ai la loutre on si vous n'êtes pas
prêt ouais bien sûr j'ai fait beaucoup
d'acide hyaluronique
mais j'ai attendu un certain âge
professeur à où il aboie
et puis très important les influences us
devrait pharmacie elle assume mais par
contre à chaque fois que je fais une
story quand je parle de mes chirurgie je
préviens aussi des risques et ça c'est
important que les influences choses qui
font de la chirurgie préviennent sur
leur story des risques elles ont droit
de le faire parce qu'elles doivent se
montrer tel quel son mais ça ne veut
absolument donner les risques des
opérations que tu fais sur tes réseaux
sont aussi comme à des rejets jsms très
intéressant de hugo qui s'occupe d'une
hausse d'associations victimes de
harcèlement à l'école notamment il me
dit la chirurgie esthétique est beaucoup
certaines victimes de harcèlement
scolaire qu'on accompagne
c'est vrai bien sûr c'est vrai que ça
l'abatteur la réflexion sur le cercle
vicieux dont vous parlez dans lequel ils
vont tomber vous faites abstraction
complètement du médecin du chirurgien en
france on a des charges un responsable
le chirurgien refuse plus de neuf
adolescents sur 10 donc vous avez
l'impression que ces vendeurs de boxe là
et qu'ils choisissent et qui font pas du
tout il ya l'obsède de la charge y ait
un look stade des quinze jours de
réflexion et à l'obstacle de la région
avec des psychologues
sauf que vous savez faire ce maxi colog
et pour les jeunes
on ne touche pas s'en laver du psycho
sydney sauf que vous savez très bien le
savez pas ce que vous me l'avez dit que
pour un chirurgien qui refuse la elles
vont faire le tour des chirurgiens pour
en trouver pour trouver celui qui dira à
l'étranger c'est moins cher que vous
dire tout le monde a refusé de faire la
poitrine de benjamin finalement il a
trouvé quelqu'un voilà c'est simple
voilà je dis encore qu'à place cet été
c'est ni fait ni à faire là où il ya le
cercle vicieux façon vous fassiez
attention à ça c'est bien de plus en
plus de réalisateurs qui refusent
d'engager des jeunes femmes qui n'ont
plus aucune expression
moi j'en ai entendu plusieurs le dire
moi mais celle ci je l'apprends pas
parce que les gens ont fait plein de
trucs
elle n'a qu'une expression et c'est un
vrai danger ce que mason ce témoignage
une censure est ce que les cliniques à
vous demande de faire de la pub puisque
normalement et n'ont pas loin de faire
la pub pour des actes médicaux alors non
c'est interdit mais on m'a déjà demandé
de faire de la pub pour des
de la médecine esthétique qui m'attire
des injections et sa marque on le savait
parce que j'estime que j'ai quand même
une responsabilité mais si je pense que
les gens qui me regardent sont pas tout
à ce que des fléchettes que vous mettez
un poste on vous offrir les noms on a
composé mais je ne fais pas ça quand je
paye foyers seraient mal mais je
commence cette affaire ça commence à
faire
c'est vrai oui c'est 500 euros les
lèvres un peu comme 1 300 euros les
lèvres à papa 300 euros les 9 mais il
faut le faire il a choisi ou plein il
faut pas le faire à huit mois des
tranquillement comme paribas a démontré
qu'avec toi tu mens tu es comme athmane
flamenco et là tu veux plus la mefou
quoi labeaume et sans risque c'est un
truc de fou
j'ai vu ça dans l'avion la dernière fois
il y avait deux livres lui noté son bal
de paroisses en euros pour les lèvres ça
devrait tous les six mois
nous laissions ça et pour le 400 euros
vous connaissez bien roulé fait george
clooney et arrivent très bien ah ouais
je viens vous connecter tarifs je le
fais moi moi j'ai fait les paupières à
cause de vous c'est fait les paupières
parce que c'est loupé un regard
malicieux c'est super ça lui donne un
regard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une question au docteur ya pas un nom en
données où ça change la personnalité
parce que et en règle générale il ne
supporte pas de se voir avant c'est à
dire que il gomme complètement l'image
d'avant magali est ce que tu assumes
toutes les photos qui a de toi avant où
es tu te retrouves face facilement ou
pas du tout en fait j'ai du mal mais
j'avais rappelle-toi j'avais j'étais pas
bien plate ou un jour au tir il avait
mis une photo de moi avant mais en fait
ça me oui ça me fait ça me blesse parce
que je n'ai très mal vécu j'étais
j'étais pas bien dans mon corps et dans
ma tête donc appartient au moment où je
suis malheureuse j'estime que j'ai le
droit à mon âge de refaire ce qu'il faut
pour me sentir bien si ses patrons
français 35 ans cinq ans oui mais même
une fois 35 ans de souffrance pour aller
mieux
non elle alors qu'elle a eu envie
d'aller mieux tout de suite j'ai pas
envie d'attendre
voilà qui serait tu es heureux de
nombreuses années tant souffrir ou
encore compensé téléspectateurs et où
pour 10%
c'est très peu contre 90% voilà bombail
à 10%
c'est déjà pas mal ça fait dix ans et
c'est plus que plein de gens aux
élections merci signer ça contredit une
étude qui vient d'être publiée
80 % de lait des gens actuellement pense
qu'ils seront un jour une opération de
chirurgie esthétique mais là c'est pour
les codes dans le temps c'est très
possible
vous savez jamais temps s'est jamais
fait de chirurgie esthétique rien fait
vous non j'ai rien fait je ne ferai pour
lancer le film après moi j'ai très peur
mais en fait ça là mais rien là bas donc
est ce pour ça serait plein de choses si
un jour j'aimerais tellement vous
ressemblez où vous un bloc de 9
il ya des opérations pour les âmes et
tous les ans je sais mais moi j'ai très
peur moi de tout ça moi comment on fait